I am talking about the eight pro-life
Advocates who are currently in jail and
facing 11 years behind bars for
peacefully protesting at an infanticide
Mill The Operators of which were proven
to have regularly violated federal law
conducted illegal abortions deprived
babies born alive of federally mandated
medical care and hidden their Crimes by
improperly disposing of the baby's
bodies the abortionist in charge
admitted to these sorts of crimes on C
eight pro-life Advocates peacefully
demonstrated against the clinic Lauren
handy John Henshaw Heather Roni William
Goodman herb gity Joan Bell Jonathan
Darnell and Jean Marshall these pro-life
Advocates unlike the infanticidal
butcher that they were protesting
Chesire s Angelo have never killed
anyone they would never hurt a fly and
yet they are currently sitting in jail